[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him Goble Goble
gobble that's right Republicans are
willing to lie about Thanksgiving turkey
although I don't think Jason chaus is
actually
lying he's just an elite piece of
[__] it was really funny um yesterday
I think of yesterday sometime Jason
former representative Jason chaus I
don't remember if you guys remember this
piece of [__] he gave up his
congressional seat to go be a
contributor on Fox
News professional
gaslighter and last night he on some I
think it was on Kaylee mcan's show he
said that that he paid $90 for a turkey
and the internet immediately was like oh
turkeys don't cost $90 and they went to
walmart.com thinking that Jason chaitz
would buy a butterball a frozen butter
ball or something get the [__] out of
here that guy would never be caught dead
in a normal grocery store with the pores
no [__] way would that guy ever be
caught dead in a grocery store with the
pores no [__] way he ain't buying he
ain't buying the turkeys that you're
buying he ain't going to no goddamn
grocery store I'm going to show you
where Jason chaitz more than likely
bought his $90 turkey and I actually
think that he didn't buy a full turkey
he paid
$90
$90 for a breast I'm not kidding
you Jason chaus is an elite he's a
Washington DC Republican Elite at
that and you think you think this
[__] walked down to the Piggly
Wiggly and got a [__] Frozen
Butterball
turkey you don't know Republicans very
well and I I I saw it all over Twitter
like everyone was po even my post they
were posting screenshots from
walmart.com and
kroger.com even if you went to like
Whole Foods Jason chaffers be like Whole
Foods
yuck those people wear hay dudes in that
store he's a [__] elitist all of them
are elitist the craziest part right is
everyone was
postulating on the
internet like how do the people watching
Fox News believe this
[__] right like how in the [__] do these
ninka poops go to
Walmart are there or their local grocery
store and buy turkey for $2 a pound this
time of
year and not understand that if Jason
Chait bought a $90 turkey that turkey
would be the size of
me no [__] way did Jason chaitz buy a
$90 turkey or did he I'm actually
saying I think that Jason chaitz
actually did buy
a $90
turkey there's a farm in
Virginia and they sell premium Farm
Fresh turkeys this goes with the farm
fresh fash Uncle Facebook Fred doesn't
it goddamn the storyline I tell you what
all these characters just line up in
this fascist soap opera doesn't
it I really think Jason chaitz went and
bought this turke
turkey and it's called kelly
bronze is where he went and bought it
and I'm sure that Jason chaitz he had a
whole Fleet of [__] SUVs that took
him and his family out there they
probably took three or four outfits they
probably took a photographer so they
could take pictures on the farm I'm sure
they met the owner of the farm I'm sure
they paid to do the full [__] tour
and paid to take pictures on the farm so
they could hang him up and his you know
God knows how many millions of dollars
he has and however many houses he
has and the internet's like hey turkey
doesn't cost that much at
Walmart and this is why I do the show
this this and I know it feels
weird that I'm making a big deal out a
out of Jason chaet saying he paid $90
for a turkey but I actually think he did
pay $90 for a turkey I think he actually
did I think J it's been a long time
since Jason Chait has ever walked into
or even been close to a [__]
Walmart or a [__] grocery store
there's no way there's no way Jason
chaitz or his family would ever go into
a store with a bunch of normies
nope let alone being anywhere close to
[__] MAA because if you've ever the
website people PE People of Walmart you
know you
know that probably
56% of anyone past 10 o'clock in the in
the evening at walart are [__]
manga
100% I mean 50% 100% of the
[Laughter]
time but Jason chaet would never be
anywhere where would
shop and do their their grocery shopping
no [__] way you can't convince me and
again I know I know that it feels like
he's lying because that's the first
instinct because that's probably a good
guess that he's [__]
lying I'm gonna show you this [__]
website where a nine pound turkey follow
me a nine pound whole turkey cost
$133 and everyone on the [__]
internet wasted their time posting
screenshots from
walmart.com to Jason chaitz to tell him
how much a normal turkey as if he wants
to eat the turkey that you would settle
for he he has been crooked for a long
time so that he can afford these type of
turkeys
okay he has made sure to undermine the
the American middle class so he gets a
leg up so he can afford a $90 turkey
breast because I actually think that's
what Jason chait's bought and honestly I
would welcome that [__] fascist [__]
on this show to explain himself why he
paid $90 for a turkey
breast he
did he's not lying I know you want to be
lying I know the internet wants him to
be lying we all want him to be lying on
Fox News because that's typically what
they do is
lie but I don't think he's lying and he
gladly the thing is he's disingenuous
right and he's spreading misinformation
because he's an [__] he's a fascist
nazi and he's got a Gaslight [__] Fox
News viewers who go down to the local
Kroger and pay $2 a pound for a frozen
turkey
and they're sitting there going did you
hear that they're they're paying $90
wherever Jason Chait is at [__] the
turkey that's in our refrigerator that
goddamn thing was only 239 a pound we
got a hell of a deal Jan we got a hell
of a deal God damn can you believe that
can you believe that I can't believe
these Biden omics Biden omics charging
Jason chapit $90 for a butter ball [__]
out of here with that
nonsense
but again Jason chaitz kind of won if
you look at it through that through that
lens he kind of
won because he wasn't lying about how
much he paid for this thing and he
willingly paid that that's the
misinformation in the gaslighting is
he's acting like oh my God it's so
egregious that I paid $90 for a turkey
breast when he willingly paid that he
wanted to pay
that he went to this farm with his
family I
bet they made a whole weekend out of
going and getting the Thanksgiving
turkey breast that cost him
$90 and he had the last laugh because
the internet was posting
screenshots from Normie poor poor poor
people grocery stores that's how he
views it because he again he would not
be [__] caught
dead shopping with the pores no [__]
way would you ever catch Jason
jitz
anywhere in an American retail store
with the pores no [__] way that's why
he's on Fox
News duh don't you know that it's a
requirement I mean Jesus Christ they
worship a guy who claims his house in
South Florida is worth a billion and a
half dollars and you're going to try to
convince me that they don't think
they're [__]
elitist that's where I started when I
seen this clip of Jason Chait and it's
only like two seconds long and I know
I'm going on and on and on and on and on
about Jason chaitz saying that he paid
$90 for a turkey but I want people to
[__] understand why he said
it again people just went to oh he's
lying H we got him H we got you [__]
who really schooled you we really fooled
you Jason
but Jason's getting the last laugh
because he wanted to pay $90 for that
turkey
breast he thinks that turkey breast is
better than any turkey breast that
you'll get I bet on Thanksgiving when he
[__] when he he Forks it up to his
mouth and he puts it in his mouth he's
like oh baby only the elitist of the
elite Americans get to eat turkey like
this this is turkey made for the elite
El rich people not you
Poes look at all you pores out there
eating your eating your regular Normie
grocery store Frozen butter
balls I'm eating me a farm fresh
premium turkey breast and this
farm this
Farm they've got a farm in the UK and
they got a farm in
Virginia that's it
that's it they got two
farms and this Farm I don't know how
much the owners how much money they got
but I bet they got a shitload of money
if they're selling N9 pound turkeys at
$133 folks we got to stop treating these
Republicans like we're going to own
them we got to get down and figure out
what the [__] they're talking
about I try to do it all the time
yesterday people were [__] pissed off
at me well there's a few people and a
few people said I'm leaving I'm not
gonna listen to Tony
anymore okay you're back today I
bet because I because I pointed out why
Glenn kersner on the 14th Amendment is
[__]
wrong and you're mad at me you're mad at
me
that's
hilarious and someone said that that I I
I talk down to my
audience most people here are getting
what I'm I'm saying they're smelling
what I'm stepping
in they're smelling what I'm stepping
in and they [__] get
it listen if you want
me to just tell you what you want to
hear you're in the wrong [__]
place you need to go to another Channel
if you're just wanting someone to tell
you what you want to
hear I've never said what you want me to
say I've always said what I
think I should have the commentary
for that's why the microphone is
here
we got to get
right we can't [__] this next year up
and I know we're not going to I'm very
optimistic about
this very
optimistic because so many so many
people understand what's at
stake and it's not just it's not just
Trump
winning that's not the only thing at
stake I mean we we watched as Argentina
yesterday voted in their own
Trump and I and I actually I'm kind of
excited about it if you want to know the
honest truth because all these righties
here in this country are super excited
that that [__] Nazi got elected in in
Argentina and this Nazi in Argentina is
totally gonna [__] that country up in
the next six months totally [__] it
up and ways you can't even
imagine and the righties in this country
will be [__] silent silent on
it because that's what fascism does it
ruins
Nations especially when you're so
[__] avert about it he's going to
smash up the government he's going to
smash up their entire infrastructure for
their social safety net good do it do it
set the example and watch the righties
in this country cheer him as he does it
and then when their [__] Nation falls
apart then we can point out how that's
what they want here because what he's
doing there is Project
2025 that's what his plan is is Project
2025 which is a fascist takeover of a
democracy that's the plan
there good news is is it's hell of hell
of a far ahead of
us and it ain't it won't take long folks
it won't take long for that country to
be in absolute turmoil for the people
that voted for that scumbag to be
wanting that scumbag
out and I talked to someone yesterday
and I said I don't I'm not really sure
of Argentina's election laws you know
I'm not really
sure um but
they I said and I don't know if they
have a recall you know if he'll be
recalled and they said I think I think
the recall uh law in Argentina is a
bullet and I'm like well you know I mean
I can't say that I know or don't know
that but it's GNA get really hairy in
Argentina really fast and even people
who voted for him are going to regret it
almost
immediately because when you elect
someone like that that is willing to
smash up an entire nation's social
safety net that has been built over
decades and decades and decades and
people have put in a lot of serious hard
work into building a social safety net
for its nation and for its people and
then they go vote against that interest
they realize really quick that they were
the [__] ones that got
duped folks if Maka elects Trump in this
next election they're going to suffer
the most almost
immediately I don't know if you know
that rural areas are poor broke and have
no [__] money the only money that
rural areas have in this country are
federal dollars almost every single
[__] dollar that goes into rural
communities [__] comes from the
federal government down to the state
into those Ral communities because
without those federal dollars that the
state takes and puts in those Ral
communities they would have nothing
nothing no economy no jobs no
nothing they don't even [__] realize
that the federal safety
net keeps their Community the way that
their Community is they have no [__]
clue no [__]
clue and it's no more obvious than than
them supporting Donald Trump and someone
who is willing to smash up
the social safety net and voting for
Republicans who want to kill their
social security and take away their
Medicare that's one of the biggest
federal
dollars that supports rural
communities is social security Medicare
and
Medicaid where do you think the dollars
come from in those
communities do you think the farm bill
do you think the [__] farm bill
doesn't keep [__] rural communities
aoat where do you think that money comes
from
it doesn't come from private
corporations you stupid [__]
boneheads and you guys think that J
Jason Chait ain't paying $90 for a
[__]
turkey he's using his goddamn federal
pension and his big [__] Fox News
contributor contract to pay for that $90
and all the [__] money he crookedly
stole and probably all the insider
trading that that some [__] did when he
was a
congressman that's what he used to pay
that $90 and the rule people sitting
around cheering project 2025 cheering
fascism like in
Argentina because PE because elitists
like Charlie [__]
Kirk think that it's a good
idea these people are listening to Ben
Shapiro and Charlie Kirk elitist they
probably paid $200 for their [__]
turkey they didn't go to the [__]
pores grocery store
neither no way no how not going to
happen and until we [__] understand
what's going
on and Argentina electing this
fascist and him smashing up the I mean I
don't want that for
argentinians argentin what is
it how what is it argentinians I don't
know [__] I don't know I don't know
shows how much I give a
[__] hey you elected the guy you you
elected in your democracy someone who
wants to destroy your
democracy and when you do that you think
I'm going to stand back and say well it
really hurts me inside
that that the people in
Argentina who decided that it was a good
idea to use their Democratic
vote to smash up democracy in
Argentina they thought it was a good
idea they they're gonna have a rude
awakening very [__] quick almost
immediately I don't know if you seen the
video of this guy this guy's like
[__] he's like get that we're getting
rid of Education we're getting rid of
the the environmental I mean it's just
so trumpy it's so [__]
trumpy I mean I I don't know if anyone's
[__] put Trump's face on that video
yet where he's talking about smashing up
the social safety
net the
government that the Argentinian people
have
built over Decades of serious serious
policy and you know what's crazy is is
that the rightwing is like look haha the
Socialists in Argentina are sad haha we
owned the
libs right-wingers in this country are
excited that a fascist government is
going to destroy democracy in Argentina
and the libs got
owned they're going to have a root
Awakening
too and the reason why is because we're
going to use it as an example we're
going I'm I'm going to point it
out as as the AR Argent Argentina
economy
Falls and the country get is in a
whirlwind of
turmoil and he's recalled
recalled I'm gonna show
you what will happen here for project
2025 because that's that's really
that is really what they want
here it's crazy all right I got a few
pieces of business to take care of I got
a birthday uh in the chat it's a very
important birthday Amanda is a great
moderator of ours Amanda it's your
birthday and you know for birthdays I
sing Happy Birthday and this is very
important so everyone wish Amanda our
our great moderator in the chat happy
birthday happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you so Amanda happy
birthday to you and thank you for being
a mod here uh everyone wish Amanda a
happy birthday in the chat also also
tonight at midnight tonight at midnight
there is going to be a promo code for
Black Friday for Merch it's going to be
for the tattoo Merch this machine kills
fascism the Tony Michaels podcast
official tattoo merch that's right I'm
going to get this tattooed on my arm so
you'll have the inspiration for my
tattoo on merch whether you want a
hoodie you want it on the front you want
it on the back there also will be a
promo code for even my cat hates Ted
Cruz and even my dog hates Ted Cruz so
be watching for that on social media at
midnight tonight the sale will run from
midnight tonight until Sunday at
midnight so that will be your Black
Friday special here uh for the merch and
I appreciate all the orders that you
guys have given now I also want to make
an announcement yesterday Rachel boffer
was on the show and we talked about her
book and I don't know if you caught it
but she said when her book comes out she
would love to do uh her book in the book
club on Discord sponsored by the library
of democracy now they just finish up
reading the obstacle is the way by Ryan
holiday they're still going through
Rachel mattow audio book so go to the
Tony michaels.com let me show you how to
get there you go to the Tony
michaels.com you just pan down the page
to the memberships and the book club is
right here you will have to join the
Discord that is where the book club is
at they have discussions you guys get to
read the books you do the audio books
but Rachel boffer Dr Rachel boffer is
going to join you probably in February I
would imagine that's when her book I
think February 6 is when her book comes
out
um so she said she's going to join you
guys for the book club so you definitely
want to get in on the book club now and
get used to it nowhere it's at that way
I I was like oh that's going to be
awesome everyone is gonna love that not
only to read Dr Rachel boff's book in
the book club but then have discussions
with the author author in the book club
holy [__] so I've got that announcement
so please go to the Tony michaels.com go
to Library of sponsored by the library
of democracy it's the book club again
they just finished up the obstacle is
the way by Ryan holiday they're choosing
a book right now I believe um so get
over there tell them what books you want
to read give them suggestions there's so
many people involved in the book club
and it's growing and growing and growing
and I know if we get knock to reach a
bit of Cofer in there it'll grow and
grow and grow the other thing too Mighty
librarian has on the library of
democracy's YouTube channel has a great
new video about the Heritage Foundation
telling you how they came about how this
fashist store speaking of project 2025
so just go to the tony.com pan on down
to watch and listen here and the library
of democracy YouTube channel is right
here click on the library of democracy
YouTube channel and go watch that video
and click the link Tree on the YouTube
channel for library of democracy click
the link tree for that Mighty librarian
we're helping her get a new mic it's a
new microphone so they she's got a
microphone fund over on the link tree
she's got a $100 goal and I I think
she's almost halfway there so she only
needs a few more people to get a brand
new microphone so her audio is
crisp
chis so make sure you do that you guys
are the greatest audience in the world
and you guys know it's Tuesday it's Taco
Tuesday it's Texas Paul Tuesday hang in
there don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again your's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day here's
tamy [__] them [__] them [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show some
people in the chat are asking if we have
zip hoodies for the tattoo merch Hills
yeah we do they're in the store you just
go to Theon mich.com
click the link let me show you here let
me show you uh what it what the what
they look like let me let me give you an
idea of this merch so you guys can see
it here here's the zip hoodie right here
that's the zip hoodie we got long sleeve
shirts we got short sleeve shirts
there's stickers you can put on your
laptop or anywhere these even can go on
cars if you want to put them on car
windows there's the just the the the
regular hoodie with the logo on the back
there's coffee mugs there's logo on the
front of hoodies there's women's short
sleeve shirts tote bags posters uh
there's a crop hoodie even a lot of a
lot of ladies like the crop hoodie so
there's that
coasters you can get the the logo on the
back of a t-shirt you can get a metal
print or a canvas so they're all there
oh and I want to point out we got the
camo fuckum hats now too so there's the
camo fuckum hats if anyone wants to
wants to grab those so we do have the
zip hoodies um and again the those those
promo codes will drop tonight at
midnight on social media and then
tomorrow I'll give you the promo code on
the show and they'll be good all through
the weekend all through Thanksgiving
weekend yeah it has the small logo on
the back and then the the the big logo
on the front so there's the there's the
front and then there's the back so it's
a zip hoodie with the small logo on the
front and the big one on the back and
there's black blue and gray
um so there you can see it's on the back
so go go scope it out scope it out be
watching social media and then listen
tomorrow and you'll get that promo code
and you'll be able to get a Black Friday
special um on the tattoo merch if you
haven't gotten your tattoo merch
already all already I'm gonna show you
this
website where where because Jason Chavis
did not buy this turkey off the website
he went to the farm he went to the farm
because I'm sure they got like I'm sure
it's beautiful farm and they got all
kinds of [__] money you know they're
selling they're selling turkeys to rich
people you know I almost bet Harland
Hitler bought Clarence Thomas and all
his other bought and paid for justices
and politicians I bet he bought them
turkeys too from this Farm oh [__] yeah
you got you better bit your ass this is
where they get these their [__]
turkeys from $130 for a 9 pound turkey
that didn't sound elitist enough to you
that didn't sound Republican enough to
you come on man come
on let's see if uh Texas Paul if he goes
to to the the wall fart down the road or
if he goes to a to an elitist farm and
pays $90 for a turkey breast Texas Paul
how much did you pay for your
Thanksgiving turkey uh 54 cents a pound
my friend we bought two of them because
we're having a big old shindig over here
but 54 cents a pound for couples 18
pound turkeys so you do the math on
that it's insane that people thought he
was lying it's good to be here brother
but I'm pissed off man I am telling you
I cannot I am it's like freaking catty
Shack over here man goddamn moles are
like they're like hillbilly neighbors
they are I had a damn mole in my
backyard I I've I've ordered some
ammonium nitrate I am not kidding I got
some diesel some ammonium nitrate and
some blasting caps I've had enough of
this [__] I was all Mr Nice I had in my
backyard I had a mole in my backyard
Tony audience a and I and audience I
want to tell you that um Texas Paul may
not be here next week he may be having
surgery to reattach his arms um because
he's exploding exploding moles in his
yard I just want to warn everybody if
Texas ball a't here next Tuesday he's uh
he's done lost a finger or two I now
that you mentioned that Tony actually I
need to tell you I'm not gonna be here
next Tuesday okay we need to we need to
work something out man I I'll come
another day whatever you want but but I
got an MRI next Tuesday M MRI MRI like I
said he's gonna go get his fingers
reattached from explo exploding moles no
man I'm Tony seriously man I am like Mr
conscientious I don't want to kill the
guy you know he's just trying to live
his best life out in my country backyard
so I did I did the castor oil thing and
I don't know if you've ever done that
that you can get rid of moles with
castor oil you mix it in a sprayer and
you soak your backyard and it smells
like holy hell Tony my backyard for a
month re I don't know if you've ever
smelled castor oil and the dogs would
come in they'd smell like it but I'm
like okay I'm being environmentally
conscious not dumping poison and and
this little mole didn't have to die well
this little some [__] came back with
every damn relative he has got and moved
into my yard they are in my backyard
they're in my front yard they're on my
side yard they everywhere Tony I have
had enough brother and I I'm taking I am
taking advice on how to kill moles
because right now I I have a dump
truck I got some advice for you here's
what I suggest i' suggest go take the
turkeys back to the grocery store return
those and just have mole for just cook
you up some mole for for Thanksgiving
each person can have their own their own
little mole for know they got that good
handle on the back of them I thought you
gonna say keeping Frozen just go out
there and start clubbing some [__]
with turkey you oh my God here here
here's here's an image of um Texas
Paul's backyard
[Laughter]
um oh my God there's the moles see we we
always had the U the press in traps U
but we rarely use them see well what we
do in Missouri is you just grow tall
fescue and tall fescue has a real big
root system and if you get the root
system you know big enough underneath
the underneath the surface then the
moles stay down below the the root
system because that's where the worms
and the grub will be below the root
system that's my that's my suggestion is
grow some good turf but you're in Texas
I I got cow pasture out back and we grow
Baya grass because it's high protein if
you fertilize it the cow's freaking love
it and it and it that [__] will beat the
[__] out of Bermuda grass man I mean it
I've never seen anything like Bea grass
it will it will take over every damn
thing so I just went with it man I
fertilized it keep it mowed down and
this that and that
little I'm not going to say it I'm
telling you man I that's what I was
doing I'm all sweaty man look at me man
my hair's
I'm all sweaty right now I've been
outside battling moles all morning Texas
Paul's going to Dynamite him some
gophers and cook them for Thanksgiving
speaking of Thanksgiving and cooking did
you see this video of Jason chaitz say
that it was $90 for a turkey have you
seen this I did I did and I got to agree
with you man they you know people I I
put it out there myself I was like look
I paid 54 cents a pound for a turkey
this guy is either a really full of [__]
or be you know they've got them deals
Tony where you can hire a chef a lot of
a lot of good lot of really good by the
way if you need a side gig next year to
make a lot of money this is a good way
to do it there's a lot of people that
make a lot of good money they will
prepare turkeys for families for people
and I don't mean like poor families I
mean Rich families like Jason chaitz
they will cook their turkeys for them
and then they charge them 10 times what
a turkey costs man so it's either yeah
he went and got him one of those Gourmet
we massage the turkeys you know we'd
give them manicur wait wait wait is is
that a thing is that what they're doing
are they giving them massages and
manicures and painting their nails and
[__] I swear to god dude there are there
are Cattlemen around here that have gone
to raisin
bison they treat those bison like you
would not believe man the cows are like
ah screw them they'll be fine you know
food food water them in the ass with
some antibiotics every once worm warm
them a bit and then you're good and then
freaking bison that that will you know
they're they're like assault cows you
know I mean th those dumb asses will get
out there and they will you know massage
their necks and I mean it's it's
freaking insane and then they turn
around they crossbreed these [__] and
sorry they crossbreed sorry for what
you're on the Tony Michaels podcast you
can say whatever the [__] you want we're
not on Facebook right now we're still B
from Facebook
so they will crossbreed these things and
then they will sell them and they sell
them Tony they they sell them people buy
this [__] it's like Grizzly bison meat
you know think about that Tony it's a
wild it's a wild cow do you think it's
like Angus no have you ever had B have
you had it yes yes yes quite a bit
actually you know I mean it was a big
thing for a while and I have to tell you
they crossbreed it with a cow that makes
a decent carcass you know and and then
people pay astronomical rates for this
stuff man I me I'm talking over 20 bucks
a pound for this stuff you know so
people will buy crazy [__] I'm telling
you and Damon so I think Jason chaitz is
just out there either like you said he's
either out there buying one of those I'm
gonna show you I'm gonna show you where
he bought it from I'm gonna show you I
know this is where this sun [__] bought
this from but Damon here says turkey
hand jobs that may be true too they may
be looking to um got to keep keep I mean
got to keep those turkeys happy yeah I
mean [__] you know what I mean happy
turkey is a delicious turkey you know
what I mean you know what I mean
um happy ending turkey spurt
spurt the chat went way off the rails
when you said turkey massages um um
turkeys and drag how about that are
dressing and drag yeah yeah why not why
not why wouldn't they why wouldn't they
um here is a here's a let me see I've
got a I've got an image of Jason cha why
[Music]
youbody to pay you
money yeah you're breaking up I don't
know what's wrong with this connection
let me show you this picture while Texas
Paul gets his connection get some I lost
your connection go ahead go ahead here
here is here's go ahead go ahead man I'm
sorry I talk too much I'm sorry here's
here's Jason Chait um in the middle of
the table I'm not sure what's going on
here rant I'm not sure what's happening
at the library if or the laboratory if
the laboratory thinks that Jason cha
doesn't have legs but apparently he
doesn't have legs or's sitting on the
table with his $90 turkey here now
that's that's some turkey that looks
like hand job turkey to me uh in a
ballroom like that that looks like
exactly where where he would where he
would eat the turkey let's see I've got
I got some more images here um but I
want I want to show you this video um I
want to she oh this is going to scare
the [__] out of you Paul you want to get
some here's your Thanksgiving dinner
here's your Thanksgiving dinner right
here I know it's coming I'm telling you
them you you're from Missouri brother
you understand what I mean by hillbilly
neighbors man you understand what
they're like you piss off fighting their
whole family you know I was the
hillbilly neighbor what the [__] are you
talking about yeah yeah here's here's
plotting for Paul here's the uh the
Gopher Army coming from the cattle field
to Texas Paul's backyard and he thinks
he's going to bomb these people he
thinks he's going to fight them I swear
God No More Mr Nice Guy no more no more
Mr caster oil no more M no when they got
pitchforks and torches these look like
gopher fascist I'm not going to lie they
look like they were at Charlottesville
or something but here I want to show you
speaking a fascist let me show you uh
this video from uh Jason Chait on Fox
News it's not very long it's just long
enough to piss you off listen up here I
mean we went to go buy a turkey today it
was $90 for a turkey the price of stamps
is up 32% in the last four years but
it's all a choice by Joe Biden that is
what bomic
is okay so he's pissed off about the
turkey he bought he chose to buy a $90
turkey and then he throws stamps in
there I don't where he get stamps hey
Jason Jason do what everyone else does
and do online bill pay for crying out
loud Jesus [__] Christ what the [__]
what are you bitching about stamps for
man and besides you think Joe Biden and
the president of United States controls
who stamps is no it's the post office
and the post office general what the one
that we have now was appointed by oh
what the [__] his name Trump you
[__] bonehead how are you bitching
about how is he bitching about stamps
Texas Paul how's he bitching about
stamps over the last four years over the
last four years he says they've gone up
32% Joe Biden hasn't been president for
four
years I you know I can't believe that
they don't freak out about the post
office more with all their conspiracy
theories and [__] I really because you
know they're all like the military we
got to have our AR15s you know the
military might come the post office
comes to every house in
America six days a week now seven they
work on Sundays now people they come
with the Amazon delivery they got
compete with the Amazon delivery you
know and you're pissed off that they're
charging you a buck to show up I won't
show up folks I will not show up at your
house unless it's like a social thing
and I know you and we're getting along
and then I'll show up for free but I
will not show up at your house for under
four figures I will not that it's that
simple I you see me speaking out for
somebody no I got over a four fig
paycheck okay that that's my speaking
fee right now I want to be one of them
some [__] that has one of them six
figure speaking fees one day but I'm not
there
yet don't [__]
about the post office showing up at your
house for a dollar just don't do it
they're gonna come get your letter from
your box at your house and take it
anywhere you want in this
country for a
dollar that's cheapest [__] thing on
the market huh well let me show you
what's not cheap the turkey that uh and
I think it's a turkey breast that he
actually B I love I love the old boy in
the I love the old boy in the chat he's
counting decimal
points I got four figes with a decimal
point right in the middle well hey hey
man you you you say it they'll goof on
you I'm telling you all right here is
here's where he bought his here's where
he bought his turkey from folks all
right so this Farm is from back in the
Day in the UK now on their front page
you can see there's a video going in the
background here and it's talking about
[__] the queen eating their turkey
it's talking about mar mar Margaret
Thatcher eating their [__] Turkey
right bronze turkey sell out November 95
96 97 oh man these are Elite turkeys
look the finest and the elitest of the
elite eat these turkeys now you can
order from the US Farm which is in
Virginia or you can order from the UK
Farm of course Jason chaitz is probably
going to go to the farm in Virginia
because he lives near DC because that's
what happens when you get in DC and then
you become a Fox News contributor you be
continue to lobby and you continue to be
members of think tinks and Boards in DC
and you live in DC he's not he does
actually live in Colorado I mean he's
got a house in Colorado but he didn't
actually live in Colorado much anymore
he hangs around DC Jason jait does
because he's a piece of [__] and that's
the reason why he gave up up his seat
because it was more lucrative to give up
his seat but here you go here is here is
the turkeys the Kelly bronze turkeys now
let me show you this if you go to the
order from the USA Farm
now again I want to be clear on this
they're selling turkeys based on the
[__] holiday right this isn't like
these people are selling turkeys
throughout the year they only sell them
certain times of the year let's go to
the Thanksgiving Tab and let's see how
much these turkeyy cost oh here's a
whole Kelly bronze look at that Texas
Paul doesn't that look just [__]
delicious look at that that looks like a
good turkey I'm not goingon to
lie if you show the farm man they don't
have turkey pens you know how you
normally see a house with no they got
individual turkey sweets they got these
little cucumber slices when the turkeys
go to sleep at night they're giving them
hand jobs top of their head with little
cucumbers so they don't wake up with
puffy eyes I mean but here is here's
bone in breast and here is it's now sold
out and I almost guarantee you this is
what Jason chait's actually he drove to
the farm and Texas Paul my bet is that
Jason chaitz had a fleet of SUVs that
drove to this farm with him because not
only did he bring his family to this
Farm but they brought photographers they
brought makeup artists they brought
hairdressers they bought all kinds of
crew of people so him and his family
could go out there and they could take
pictures on the farm they can hand pick
out their turkey that the breast is
going to come from all this [__] yeah
well you know the farm has that red
carpet Runway I mean you've got to you
know the turkeys just walk over you're
you think I'm making this [__] up I'm
telling you they have a they have a
[__] gift they have a receiving area
they have a receiving area they got a
gift shop I'm telling you this [__]
place is Elite of elite of elite and I
bet there's pictures of all kinds of
famous Americans and politicians that
have come and spent $90 on a turkey
breast at their [__] Farm um flea bag
Boogie says turkey
porn yeah it is turkey porn isn't it I
hand of God 100% believe you Tony that
like I was telling you about these
freaking bison Hawkers man that that
just cracks me up because that thing is
walking gristle man it is walking
brisket that whole damn bison is walking
brisket they have set up restaurants out
at their ranches you come out there
they'll serve you a nice Cabernet little
Tinder loin a bison and you know you're
paying $120 $150 a plate yeah I have
seen this crazy [__] Tony I believe you
100% that is what Jason chaitz is
sitting there saying and sitting on Fox
News bitching about that was the whole
point of my post about this this morning
Tony is these people waste their money
in incredible
ways and then they turn around and [__]
at us Democrats because they have to
waste their money in these ridiculous
backwards ass stupid ways that they
waste their damn
money well let me show you how much
money it is let me see if the audience U
agrees that Jason chaitz went to wall
fart.com and bought a turkey because
that's the thing that I saw on Twitter
like everyone kept posting screenshots
of walmart.com how much a butterball
cost I'm like that [__] ain't
going to that goddamn store and buying a
turkey there he ain't buying no goddamn
turkey in a store where the pores shop
okay he ain't been in a [__] Walmart
and God knows how long Jason cha has
been in a Walmart he wouldn't go near a
Walmart in the first place but here let
me show you how much this whole turkey
cost and let me show you why I think
this is where he got it now you go to
select the size here okay let me zoom in
here okay now this is let's select the
9B turkey 9B turkey is1 130
338 that's without the [__] tour
that's without the [__] money that
you had to pay to take the pictures on
the property that's without eating lunch
there that day that's probably without
spending $2,000 in the gift shop that
they probably spent and all the other
food and [__] they probably bought while
they were there that day now let's move
on up to you know a regular turkey 18
pound turkey to be fair Tony you get a
styrofoam cooler and and some cold packs
in there well yeah right right yeah for
133 bucks you're right but here's an
18lb turkey
$266 it doesn't change if you buy a
bigger turkey it didn't change 18 pound
turkey is
$266 now I want to be clear on this
folks Joe Biden the president of United
States this Thanksgiving is gonna be
eating one of these Kelly bronze turkeys
100% these are the turkeys that probably
go to the White House
these are the turkeys that are going to
show up at all the [__] elitist
tables and it was the the it was the
same turkey that showed up at and
Trump's White House Obama's Bush Clinton
I mean they were they've been buying
these turkeys from this Farm that's why
this Farm is in Virginia I don't know if
you know that turkey farms are usually
in the midwest there's a lot of poultry
farms in the midwest a lot chickens
turkeys Hogs even but
out in Virginia it really smells
suspicious that they wanted the elite of
the elite and why not get near
Washington why not get just close enough
for a turkey to [__] on Washington DC to
sell turkeys for
$266 folks Jason chaitz wasn't lying
about how much he [__] spent on a
turkey he wasn't lying he was just being
disingenuous about it he acted like he
was [__] upset about it he gladly
play paid $90 for his turkey that's why
he's having the last laugh he's like H
you pores don't even know that I paid
$90 for my turkey and I wanted it that
way
ha I own the libs because everyone on on
Twitter was like oh he's lying he's
lying turkeys are only this turkeys are
only that no he's not lying he's just
being an [__]
he's being a [__] [__] because
again I'm I'm showing you right here
look 9 lb 133 10 lb 148 11 pounds and 13
163 a 12 pound turkeys 177 how big does
your family how much turkey does your
family eat during Thanksgiving Paul you
guys get we I'm smoking at one and um Mr
Texas Paul does this amazing Cagan
turkey injected thing that's just
incredible don't blow smoke up her ass I
know she's listening don't blow smoke up
her ass no man no man she I I wait all
freaking year for this turkey Tony I'm
telling you this is I mean the bomb dude
so wait so wait wait wait a second wait
a second wait a second I want to get to
the bottom of this so Mrs Texas Paul
makes the better turkey oh yeah so why
in the hell do you smoke one she asked
me to and I do what my wife asked me to
oh I I see what it is yeah she knows
she's got the better turkey my friend
she know she's got the better turkey and
she's going to prove it God my mouth is
watering just talking about it Tony I'm
telling you she takes she does this
Cajun thing she uses Tony shash and some
vinegar and a bunch of other things and
then she's got a big old injector that
she threatens me with every
once stab that damn thing and injects it
all over that turkey man I'm oh my god
dude Oh I thought I thought you were
saying she's got something else she
threatens you with I didn't know what
talk I we we went into hand jobs and
turkeys I didn't know what what it was
she was threatening you with I didn't
know she's running around the houseing
around industrialized turkey injector
It's All Steel man you could kill some
you could stab somebody through the
sternum into their heart with this thing
man where else could it go Texas Paul
where else could it go not nowhere
nowhere I'm telling you don't screw with
my turkey man I wait all freaking year
for this bird
well it looks like it looks like your
birds on the beach here um being a
turkey influencer here I think these are
the turkeys that uh Jason chaitz wants
to wants to buy is the turkey
influencers oh my God now I I know this
seems trivial right that why am I
continuing to talk about Jason chaitz
and why is Tony saying that he's not
actually lying it's because these are
who these people are he goes on Fox News
and he spreads
misinformation and the the [__]
audience eats it up oh my
God is that the torture tool is that the
thing she follows you around the house
is that what oh you're signal
disconnected that's probably be that's
probably why do you
got he's showing he's showing us their
their their cooking tools
folks you didn't see it you didn't see
it honey bring it back bring it bring it
back in here let oh man I'm telling you
dude you can kill somebody with this
thing I'm telling you Tony I only show
my
okay check this bad boy out that that's
her turkey injector dude I'm telling you
she we've got one of those in my bedroom
too but it's got one of them them
harnesses on it you know what I
mean love this makes my turkey dude I
love this oh my God best money we ever
spent dude is the injector huh telling
you I'm telling you I love that thing
goddamn she's proud of it too she
wouldn't got it when you were talking
[__] she I
show show him show
him people are saying an hour is
probably enough they don't want any more
today they're like all right we're all
turkeyed out Paul's showing his goddamn
turkey Tony's saying this is I'm talking
about cooking turkeys I'm
talking oh [__] but until you've had one
of Mrs Texas Paul's cun injected turkeys
you have not lived dude you have not
lived man it is amazing it is I mean
amazing but yeah we cook two 18 Pounders
because we got family coming over and
then she does uh uh turkey taquitos
turkey tamales know all the leftover
stuff turkey and rice soup if you bought
the same turkey that Jason chaitz bought
28 Pounders would be 266 76 a
piece if you want 533
$534 yeah no I went I went down to Super
ones got them on sale for 54 cents a
pound what's it called what's it called
Super One super one is that is that I
shop at I we got is the norm store is
that the normal Normie store okay if you
don't want to shop at Walmart you go to
Super One it's it's where us poor folks
hang out I don't I don't waste money
Tony I don't I tell you you want to get
somebody to waste money you take a poor
guy that started out poor like us and
you give him money and he will do stupid
[__] like B bison Stakes he will I mean
not not me brother not me you mean like
Jason chaitz who buys $90 turkey breast
because that's that's why I say I think
he bought a turkey breast because
there's not one on here that is at $90
but if you go to this page here um the
turkey breasts are sold out and I would
imagine that the turkey breast um you
know you can get a four pound and it's
probably like a four pound breast for
like $90 but they're sold out so I can't
even click into
it yeah so all the all all the [__]
Washington Elite already spent their $90
on their on their four pound breast so
you know I don't I don't mean to like
break the mysticism or anything like
that but I just need to brag on my wife
for a second dude I do we shop when we
go shopping we go about every two weeks
we spend a day planning for it we
because we're going to sh shop at three
or four different stores we hit all the
sales circulars find out what we need we
don't waste money Tony we don't we're
not freaking Jason chaes we're not I
don't know about you and your family
dude but we watch every damn dollar you
know I I'm not here to piss money away
to make other people Rich because I want
to buy stupid [__] when I want to buy
stupid [__] I'll you know buy something
from a Jeep or something you
know I just but but you know I just no
man don't waste money I'm so proud of my
wife she can squeeze a quarter so hard
the damn Eagle will scream on the back
and I love her for it man I do my dad
was so cheap he could pick a dime up off
the floor with his butt cheeks that's
how
cheap yeah no I watched him do it he
could pick a dime up off the four with
his butt cheeks I'm serious I know a
woman in the carpet in the carpet too I
know a woman sweetest woman met at the
end of her life she was they were very
comfortable because they lived well Bel
beneath their means their whole life she
was at the point when she died her
husband was was a lawyer and he had died
and left her comfortable and every two
years she went and bought a
Lincoln she did a new Lincoln she would
trade the old one in but she would pay
herself a car payment because she'd
never pay interest ever for anything and
that woman at the most comfortable point
in her life if she saw a penny on the
ground she would stop what everybody's
do and run over and pick that Penny up
she would and she tell you if you said
anything she say pennies make dollars I
mean people that are comfortable Folks
at the end of their lives are
comfortable because they live below
their means and they don't waste money
they're not Jason freaking Chait they
aren't you know well they aren't yeah
here's here's more um Jason shav style
turkeys here this is what they do there
at that turkey farm they um they make
them comfortable there these are turkey
influencers these are the ones that they
you know they post on their social media
and stuff out there at the Kelly Bron's
Farm where Jason chaitz does over here
well I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad that
you're gonna have a good Thanksgiving
and that you guys are going to eat um um
injected turkey and Gophers uh for
Thanksgiving but I need to move on just
the because I think the turkey talk is
getting too much we'll probably talk
turkey tomorrow um but I I want to talk
about this this Argentinian Trump that's
going to bring project
2025 uh to to
Argentina so what do you think about
this guy in Texas fall here's the um the
super villain down there I mean and he
is kind of a cartoon super villain if
you want to know the honest truth this
is [__] wild stuff um let me see if I
can bring up a video to but go go ahead
and tell us your opinion of this of this
Argentina thing that that's happening
well the first thing that caught my
mention was the troll Farms went active
here the minute he got elected uh the
right-wingers tried to push this
narrative that this is the harbinger of
Doom for wokeness in this country and
that's what's going to happen in the
rest of the world there are no parallels
at all between Argentina and the United
States none whatsoever our economy is
leading the world uh our inflation is
some of the lowest in the world
Argentina had an inflation of over
150% that's why this clown got elected
and and folks let me give you a little
little insight into Argentina politics
is my thing okay there are two ruling
coalitions the uh the up and the
jxc uh that run Argentina they do the
election of this Outsider from an
outside Coalition Miler is not gonna be
able to do
anything he isn't he's not going to be
able to do anything because the entire
legislature is run by two coalitions the
ponis and and and the hard
writers that that have two they're not
like us we have two parties they have
like 20 parties and they form these
coalitions they're they're they're if
you took our legislature and M it it
with a parliament is what they're like
they have to form coalitions to govern
um one is um let me see if I can um uh
God damn it what is uh it's Union Porta
Patria un Patria it yeah un P Patria is
one and uh hos poor uh Cano is is the
other one I think uh camb Cambo Cambo uh
is the other one and they they hold all
of the legislature so Javier m is
is
yeah so they they they they decided to
go with the libertarian the Libertarians
said he would engage in reforms yeah
he's freaking hilarious man he's Hil I
mean he literally is like the the
Argentinian is that am I right am I
saying that right I don't give a [__]
really argentinan Arian Argentinian
Trump he's definitely the Argentinian
Trump just want two major points that I
put out there there are no parallels
between Argentina and the United States
n it's more like Brazil and Argentina
are parallels where you had they brought
in bolsonaro and then they were like oh
that was a mistake you know I me that's
the same thing that's going to happen
here but on the other hand um this guy's
awful he is aw I don't want to sound
like I'm defending this guy because I'm
not because he really is awful he is
you're nailing it he is the Argentinian
Trump he is you're absolutely right Tony
but Argentina needs some reform
socialism you we say it here all the
time Tony socialism and capitalism
there's a balance that has to be there
there is for for a country to be really
healthy and really successful Europe
does it well they do Argentina's out of
hand it's really freaking hard to do
business in Argentina they're rated way
down out of like 200 and something
Nations that they're rated
126th they're in the bottom half of
Nations to do business in
because it's so complicated there's so
many government quagmires there's
corruption there is so this guy coming
in is probably a good wakeup call for
Argentina you're right it's going to
suck oh [__] he's going to tear apart
what infrastructure what social safety
net they have almost immediately he's
going to tear it down the people who
voted for him be like whoa whoa what the
[__] I thought this was supposed to be
good for us and it's not going to be
good let me show you though what the
rightwing here is is talking about
here's here's just a Twitter feed um if
you go search Argentina oh damn it uh if
you go to like this one here here's Ben
shapir well if I could get it here's Ben
shapir
he's posting his entire show on Twitter
now which is hilarious that he's posting
his entire show um the the left weeps
over
argentinan Javier is it Mal how do you
say it Mal maler Javier M look listen
I'm not
weeping Ben and I don't give a [__]
really honestly um the way I see it
Texas Paul is what I said in the a block
is that honestly the rightwing embracing
this [__] type of fascism and
embracing this type of destruction of
democracy and destruction of social
safety nets inside of a country that
spent a long time trying to build their
social safety net what it tells me is
that these people are going to step on
this rake and I'm excited about it I'm
excited at this fool here here's another
one here's Michael nll show um he posted
this an hour ago look at this in this
pathetic let me show you this Michael
nll show he's got a blue [__] ch here
this was posted an hour ago look at this
he's got one retweet 26 likes and 934
views I'm not making that [__] up that's
on
Twitter and all these right wiers are
like oh Twitter's gonna be great it's
gonna be awesome it's going to be the
Bastion of free speech how about how's
your [__] free speech now Michael
when you say paper ballots help in
rightwing Argent Argentina president's
Victory he's yelling the quiet part out
loud in the [__] Title Here Texas
Paul Michael NOS that [__] Nazi is
look at that paper ballot help in
right-wing arent Argentina president's
Victory this a 45 minute video Michael
nolles in the daily wire is supposed to
be one of the hottest right-wing Nazi
Rags on the planet and this mother look
at this one
comment one retweet let me go to this
let me see who retweeted you think
Michael nolles is the one who retweeted
this what do you think let's if I can
I'm dead [__] serious what what what
I don't know who retweeted I'm not going
to retweet it but I can't I thought I
could figure out who retweeted this
thing man it's only on uh mobile but 28
liked it oh man hey hey Michael hey
Michael hey Michael it doesn't seem very
popular that paper ballots helped the
rightwing it doesn't seem that popular
to me only 28 people liked it on your
Twitter account you [__]
fool Tony they really thought this was
going to be a big deal they really did
that's why I I saw it I hope they keep
making a big deal about it to be honest
I did a video that I put out on Al all
my social media that morning talking
about because again what they're
counting on is that people don't
understand the politics of the region
they don't understand how the country
Works they can sit there and say oh this
guy's inevitable and look at us he he is
a he he's one of us and he's winning
because people love us therefore we're
going to win and it's bull it's it's
it's crap there are no parallels to this
country they had 150% inflation this is
a protest vote for a clown they knew
they were voting for a
clown like you said it's going to be a
disaster because the legislature he
can't get you know you're saying he's
going to destroy the social safety net
and [__] how how he can get nothing
through the legislature if you look at
the breakdown of their legislature there
are two
coalitions that run that legislature and
then they're like four little dots that
make up where this clown came from he
can't get anything done well you know
you know that makes me even happier then
because they're acting like he's going
to do exactly what Trump is going to do
in this country the rightwing that's
basically what they're saying and if he
can't do what they want him to do in
that country to you know to be like oh
look look look they're going to be
silent about it they're gonna be silent
about this guy in about two months
they're not going to be talking [__]
about this guy and the reason why is
because we're all going to pointing out
how [__] wrong they were and how
[__] ignorant they are and how much
they loved him because he was a fascist
and that's really the point is they love
fascism even though they don't know the
outcomes here's here's the video that I
want to show you um now this is
obviously not in English um but it's got
the subtitles here but as you see him
rip down these these little tabs here on
the board what he's doing is he's
ripping down um different agencies um
and Ministries as they call them there
let's
watch tourism gone culture gone
yep development environment out the
EPA women's General University out yeah
Public Works who needs that who needs
Public
Work technology and Innovation who needs
science and innovation
labor environment education don't need
that Transportation who needs transport
who needs Health really who needs Social
Development this is the guy that the
right-wing here think is their savior
down in Argentina
folks this is it this is and this is the
clown the clowning that they want here
this is why they worship bobert and
marjerie Taylor green and Matt gats and
Trump himself because they are [__]
boneheads they're fascist ninka poop
Nazis and they're idolizing this clown
in Argentina who if he had his way like
you said now I actually think he's gonna
do things that are gonna absolutely be a
pain in the ass he's gonna absolutely
[__] up Argentina he's gonna [__] it up
he's gonna do anything he can because
he's got Promises to Keep and they ain't
going to put up with him not keeping any
promises so he's going to try his
damnedest to do it um but that's what
tell what's even worse than that uh that
can happen
is Argentina needs reforms they really
do they're suffering right now a lot
Tony it their their economy is imploding
on itself um inflation is insane the
average person's really getting hurt so
we what we're going to do Anthony
blinken's going to make Argentina a
priority because they have cried for
help they have they they elected a guy
that should be nowhere near the wheels
of power just like Trump which could
destabilize the region so we're going to
do what the grown-ups do and we're going
to go down to Argentina and we're going
to try to help them with their reforms
and we're going to try to help them
maintain their their status quo as much
as possible while enacting reforms and
this guy he's not going to go in and
blow up the he wants that office bad
he's a he's another Trump he wants the
trappings of the office all of that was
a clown Show when he gets into office
he's going to want to to Curry favors
he's going to put his buddies in these
positions just like everybody else
does and God forbid we go down there and
help him be
successful in those
reforms and then you're going to end up
with a right- Winger saying look he was
one of us and look how what a great job
he did for Argentina and so we can do
that here if you just vote the same way
here which it's bull it's crap the guy
is a clown he's a clown and we're going
to do everything we can because we're
the grown-ups in the room to keep
stability in the region and keep this
clown from imploding Argentina and that
is what you should vote for is the
grown-ups the the boring [__] the stuff
behind the scenes the making the sausage
you know not the freaking ass clown
that's out there trying to Garner
attention that's what the Republican
party is in a
nutshell they're margorie Trader greens
they're Lauren boobers their ass clowns
all of them that don't do anything look
at them we're gonna shut the government
down we're gonna shut they don't do the
work they don't
govern Tony and and that's in my mind
what I see happening in Argentina we're
going to be the grown-ups again just
like Hakeem Jeff was just the grown-up
and kept the government running instead
of letting these little freaking kids
that are playing with
matches you know burn everything
down but how do you sell that at The
Ballot Box Tony I mean how do you well
that's a good question because we got to
make this equate here right because who
gives a [__] here about I ain't got do
you vote in Argentina I don't vote in
Argentina I don't get to vote there I
get to vote here though you get to vote
here right the audience gets to vote
here and you know excited because uh let
me show you something here I've been
attacking Joe Scarboro for quite some
time because Joe Scarboro is a [__]
he really is because he deserves it he
Joe Scarboro is a [__] I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna push it two ways here um
but uh this morning the right wing is
freaking out because Joe Scarboro said
something on Morning Joe I guess I
didn't watch this morning because I only
watch on Monday morning so I did watch
yesterday but apparently Joe Scaro is
going Tony Michaels on the show uh and
they're really [__] pissed off about
it and you know what excites me about it
is that Joe and his producers who come
here and listen um are actually
listening to me but Benny Johnson here
says Morning Joe Scarboro goes on
unhinged anti-trump rant uh the quote is
he will imprison and execute whoever is
allowed um so let me let me play a
little bit I haven't actually seen this
uh and but my guess is is that they're
really upset that Joe Scarboro is saying
the truth out loud that I've been saying
for years but here is here's Joe
Scarboro on morning juror this morning I
wonder how many times he cuts off maik
have a responsibility to to Really to
tune out the voices of of the haters of
of the people that are constantly double
triple checking and Shilling for him and
suggesting that somehow they're being
biased bending over backwards treating
him like a normal candidate he's not a
normal candidate okay I want to point
out to the audience here and I know
Joe's going to say some great anti-trump
stuff and I know the right WIS pissed
off at him this morning for saying
anti-trump stuff but I just want to
point out that it was Ma and Joe here
who treated Trump like a normal
politician back in 2016 would invite him
on
MSNBC anytime he called in anytime he
wanted to call in they'd have him on the
phone they did interview after interview
with him they'd [__] yuck it up with
him they pat him on the back oh Trump
you're just a clown you're not actually
going to be the president so I want to
point out I want to point out now I
don't know if Ma and Joe have um you
know apologized to the country for that
type of [__] but what he's saying here
is exactly what they did in 2016 I just
want to point that out to the audience
number one um but go ahead Joe he is
running to end American democracy as we
know it he's an authoritarian who a
court uh in in Colorado two days ago
ruled that that he led an insurrection
against the United States government
okay I also want to point out I don't
know if you're watching Joe's arm here
but he's got his arm on his knee and
he's bouncing his knee pretty hard my
guess is is that he's he's been told you
got to go pretty far on this rant Joe
you gotta go pretty [__] far on this
rant he's really nervous about going
this far because he knows he's gonna get
backlash from the right Wi on the
internet well let's listen he's charged
with leading schemes to help overthrow
the United States government so so if
they want to frame it uh that way that's
fine if if you want to be fair if you
want to be fair then you will frame this
uh as Joe Biden being the candidate that
supports American democracy and Donald
Trump a candidate who supports a new
form of government here that's
authoritarian it's really that simple
and by the way Reverend Allen people go
oh you can't compare him to past Nazi
leaders you can't compare him to this
past Nazi leader or that past fascist
leader because he hasn't done that well
what hasn't he done he hasn't done the
things that the American judicial system
did not allow him to do last time but
may very well allow him to do this time
or a judicial system that will be
ignored by Donald Trump and ran over by
Donald Trump to create the greatest
constitutional crisis of our lifetime
just because he hasn't done it yet
doesn't mean he won't do it when he gets
a chance to do it and if he has voted
into office then a lot of these people
that are talking about literal or
figurative or whatever the hell they're
saying you're gonna look like idiots uh
because he will do he will get away with
he will imprison he will execute whoever
he's allowed to impr prison execute uh
uh uh uh drive from the country ju just
look at his past it's not really hard to
read only again the only thing that
stood between him and the destruction of
American democracy was the Federal
Judiciary no the only thing that stood
between him and the destruction of
democracy was us again Joe always gets
it [__] wrong Joe is a [__]
Republic he's not a [__] liberal he's
not Joe Scarboro is not a [__]
liberal he is looking through the lens
Texas Paul and he's like oh it was the
courts that saved our country no the
[__] it wasn't it was us we told that
son of a [__] resoundingly because Paul
I've said this before 81 million people
did not vote for Joe Biden a lot of that
81 million people voted against Trump
they didn't vote for but it could have
been a [__] ham sandwich they didn't
give a [__] it was us that saved this
country it was us and Joe Scarboro can't
muster up enough [__] courage he can
muster up enough [__] courage to say
what I've been saying for [__] ever
that Trump and Republicans are [__]
Nazis and if you give them the chance to
be a [__] Nazi by God they'll [__]
lean into it and they do all day every
day at the federal level state level
county level Schoolboard level [__]
all the way down to the God damn dog
catcher these fascists if we allow them
to be Nazis they will be but Joe scarber
still can't even get it he still can't
even get it this is the stupid [__] that
I'm talking about the 14th Amendment
stuff with Glenn these people really
believe that the Judiciary that the
courts that a prosecutor is Gonna Save
this country and it ain't that is not
their [__] job it's our job Joe and
we save this [__] country we got out
there in 2020 when there was a [__]
pandemic the people stood in [__]
lines and made sure their ballots and
their voted votes counted against Trump
81 million of them you [__] and
you're gonna sit there and act like it
was the Judiciary that saved this
country and not the people who [__]
voted just because the courts upheld the
law you think that was [__] that was
a high bar to [__] match get the [__]
out of here Joe this is why this type of
[__] pisses me off and the right-wing is
all mad this morning at Joe Scaro
because he says Trump will execute
people of course he's going to of course
he's going to I've been saying it for
years hello think think Joe think I'm
glad Joe Scaro is finally finally coming
around to his senses but Joe if you're
listening or if your producers are
listening you're not there yet give me a
call buddy I'll tell you what's going to
[__] happen and how you should be
thinking about this cuz the way you're
thinking about about it is $90 turkey
breath style thinking because I I almost
bet Ma I almost bet Ma and Joe here are
going to be eating $9 turkey this
[__] week this [__] week these two
are going to be eating $90 turkey and
they're trying to tell us average
working Americans that it was the
[__] Judiciary not us that saved this
[__] country from Trump trump [__]
you Joe [__] you sorry I'm telling you
man I'm no I I hear you brother I do I'm
spping this up with a biscuit man I am
enjoying the [__] out of these people in
the mainstream media the corporate media
finally coming around we've been saying
this since
2015 you cannot give this guy power and
and and you know the the Russians have a
uh the the the opposition in Russia have
have a state uh a comment a quote it's
it's pretty good your institutions will
not protect you exactly what you're
talking about your institutions will not
protect you is what is what they tell
you when when fascism tries to step in
it's you it's you the only reason our
institutions held is because you were
out there making sure they understood
where the people were if the if we're
sheeple if we're sheeple we absolutely
will lose this government we will it is
on you to to deal with this it really is
but I I am absolutely loving I am
enjoying
100% a thousand % I am like I said
sopping it up with a biscuit and just
because I have been saying what they're
finally saying out
loud since 2015 I know you've been
screaming it too Tony it's just wow I'm
enjoying that they're finally coming to
some reality when Trump is standing on
stages in front of cameras and saying it
I'm gonna have camps I am going to go
after my political opponents I don't
give a damn yada Yad y and all of his
maggot people are like yeah yeah that's
what they're doing to you you should do
it to them no no you have to commit
crimes for us to come after you period
you have to have committed crimes and
even then they've given him so much
freaking deference it's not even funny
he's being treated like no other person
in our Judicial System would be treated
the stuff he said about this judge would
land me in
prison you know I mean it's just I'm
telling you Tony 100% I'm loving it I am
loving that the media is finally coming
around to believing what these people
are telling them to their faces you know
for years how long did we how long did
we hear oh it's they just wanted to go
back to the States abortion they just
wanted to go back to the States now what
are they saying we need a nationwide
abortion
ban what did we say the whole damn time
they want to abort they want to ban
abortion Nationwide it has nothing to do
with States right rights it has nothing
to do with a couple states don't agree
with that and they should have the
freedom to disagree that's a BS argument
they want to B ban it nationwide and
what do we telling them now the 2025
project they're telling
us us
to I think his signal got
lost defitely the
AR
Trum
yeah we lost your signal there um so
here's the thing here's the thing I
wanna I I wanna I want to Circle Mac on
this because the reason why is because I
get what you're saying about the medi
that they're coming
around but I actually don't think
they're coming around to where we want
them to come around to they're coming
around for profit I went off yesterday
on Jonathan Carl um because Jonathan
Carl is a scumbag he's a [__] scumbag
he held evidence that showed what this
this lady Cassidy Hutchinson went to the
January 6 select committee and testified
to and everyone called her a [__]
liar you're a [__] liar she's a liar
she's lying blah blah blah blah blah
Jonathan Carl paying attention to this
being a journalist in Washington and he
had a tape of
trump saying exactly what she testified
to that he did want to go to the capital
and the only reason why he didn't is
because the Secret Service wouldn't let
him and they went on and on and on and
they still go on Jesus Christ Mike
Johnson released all the 40,000 hours of
the Insurrection tape and they're taking
they're taking three clips and like see
it's not an Insurrection like yeah
you're not showing the Insurrection part
dummy like show the show the other
[__] part where they were
insurreccion their right-wing trying to
Gaslight people but Cassy Hutson went on
Jin Saki and I I again I attacked Jin
saki yesterday too for having Jonathan
Carl on and doing the stupid [__] where
they're selling books for profit they're
selling evidence for profit these
[__] journalist I will never respect
Jonathan Carl ever again ever again
Jonathan you I will not you piece of
[__] you scumbag you you sold you sold
evidence of the January 6 Insurrection
that the country should have known about
during those select committee hearings
and you held it for
profit now Cassie Hutchinson is one that
went and testified to the January 6
select
committee now some would postulate that
maybe she did it because she needed to
come to the truth and com come to Jesus
moment in her
testimony but I believe that she was
told that she needed to lie under oath
and she wasn't willing to go to prison
for
Trump but now she's saying something
completely different now folks I want to
remind you Cassy Hutchinson is very
brave okay she's brave for what she did
as far as looking at Trump and saying
I'm not going to prison for you because
a lot of them have not been that brave
it is cowardly it is cowardly not to
look at Trump and say I will not lie for
you or I will lie for you and I will go
to prison for you and I will commit you
that is cowardly that's what makes a
coward so she's not a
coward but Cassie Hutchinson worked for
Trump she wanted Trump to win folks she
knew the dangers of trump winning and
still wanted him to win but I want to
play this clip from Jin saki show
because apparently she has changed her
mind which I'm happy about but where the
hell was this energy months ago she's
just now coming to to this conclusion
after all she's been through even last
year with the select hearings listen I
know you've been reluctant to say who
you're going to vote for but would are
you leaving the door open to voting for
Joe Biden if it's between the two of
them I will say my door is completely
shut to voting for Donald Trump and the
only reason that I will
not endorse a candidate right now is
because I still am hopeful that Donald
Trump does not end up being the nominee
next year I think our country will be in
a much better Place overall not just for
myself but the ticket and the future of
her country will be but what I will say
too though is I think everybody should
vote for Joe Biden if they want our
democracy to survive oh okay so she's
not willing to vote for Joe Biden um
Texas Paul she's not willing to say yes
I'm gonna vote for Joe Biden not because
I like Joe Biden not because I'm a
Democrat but because the democracy's on
the line but she actually she's closing
the door on Trump but she's leaving the
door open that Trump's not going to be
the nomin
this is the type of [__] right-wing
delusion conservative delusion
Republican delusion Mitt Romney Style
[__] that oh our party is savable
folks the Republican party is [__]
dead they're [__] dead they're Nazis
it's it's over there are no you are not
going to [__] stuff that cat back in
the bag you are
Fascist yeah and you can't wipe the fasc
off you can't wash the fash off after
this and she still doesn't even [__]
get it what in the [__] don't they Tas
Paul Trump was inevitable Trump or
someone like Trump was inevitable
because that's what the Republican party
is that is where it's going they've
seated all their power to the
billionaire frat booy club and all of
their policies they don't appeal to the
average person anymore they don't try to
govern anymore Trump was inev
that's what was going to come out of the
Republican party and these people are
now sitting there trying to say oh
they're they're trying to push it all
off on Trump the stank they're trying to
push it all off on Trump and saying
Trump's the bad person no no Cassidy
Hutchinson you're the bad person because
you still want another Republican when
your Republican created this this is
where you're going another Republican is
not going to be is not going to be
better S will not be better thanp I bet
Cassie Hutchinson would endorse and vote
for Ronda santz oh yeah in a heartbeat
what does that tell you what does that
say what does that say and people people
get mad at me for going after going
after Cassidy Hutchinson well I'm just
listening to the word she's saying is
all I'm doing because I know the left
wing is all excited that Cassidy
Hutchinson went on Jin saki Show on
MSNBC and said everyone should vote for
Biden and oh that's that's some sort of
[__] corner turning moment listen
folks in 2020 81 million people went and
voted for democracy that's what I'm
trying to tell you that's what I'm
trying to tell you the media Joe
Scarboro Cassie Hutchinson these [__]
elitist out in [__] Washington they
don't understand us they don't get us
they don't understand how [__]
important our country is they don't
understand how much we want to keep our
lifestyle they don't understand how we
understand that we are the government it
is us not [__] you you don't [__]
rule us we rule you [__] our votes put
you in power and if you don't start
doing the [__] you're supposed to be
doing we will [__] take you out like
[__] Joe mansion and Kiron Cinema out
of power we will take you out of power
if you turn your backs on us and this is
the way it should be I know in 202
during the pandemic
when you remember the essential worker
[__] you remember that [__] they
were like oh well you have to work
because you're an essential worker and
the entire country went wait I'm
essential and I'm the lowest paid
[__] on the Chain [__] you and
then when we came out of the pandemic
corporations like why are all you be why
are all you so [__] greedy greedy
we're essential [__] we're essential to
your [__]
profit and we're essential to your
[__] power so you better get your
[__] minds right you better get your
[__] heads right because people like
Joe scar burrow and people like Cassie
Hutchinson aren't looking through the
prism of reality they don't know it's
the reason why I say I'm so optimistic
about next year because Paul folks get
it they [__] get it people get it
they don't even have to pay attention
much to get it they know how much of a
clown show that the [__] Republican
party is they can see what is coming it
doesn't take much to point it out to
them when Trump's standing on stage
calling people Vermin and talking about
[__] rounding them up and putting
them in
camps and then and the right-wing loses
are mind when Joe Scarboro who is an
elitist who thinks the courts saved our
country in 2020 which isn't even close
to the [__] truth Joe not even close
to the truth it was the voters that
saved this [__]
country and the rightwing mad that he
said that Donald Trump is going to call
for
executions you people you people out
there who have got your minds in a
situation where you're on the elite side
of [__] are not with not with the
operating perspective of America you're
not you're not yeah and that's the
probleme you 100% And and I will I'll
tell you something else you you're spot
on about Jonathan Carl you are spot on
about him it is he's a greedy [__] but I
will tell you something that that I see
in both these two I was watching
Jonathan Carl on Cole bear that man is
scared he is sincerely scared of the
[__] that he saw on the inside they
didn't tell us he saved it for his book
to try to make some money but he's
looking at another Trump presidency and
he's going inside you could just talking
to the man he could not hide the body
language he could not hide what was
coming out of him that man is
legitimately scared at what he saw
Cassie Hutchinson the same way look at
her body language look at her face she
wants very badly to save her career and
save her money but when she starts
thinking about another Trump presidency
that is legitimate fear in her face for
what she's seen and and that's where
these folks are don't look to them
they're not our friends Joe Scarboro is
not our friend he is not they're looking
at this and they're still trying to
justify in their minds why they were
right to be what they were who they were
what they did what they pushed on us
they are trying in their minds to
justify somehow that they were still
right and being Republican is still good
because that's what Cassidy Hudson
identifies as that's her tribe and she
still wants to believe that there's some
goodness there when all evidence shows
us this is what you did you have been
doing this for decades you have been
lying gaslighting screwing the American
people for decades you are not good you
are not good people and you are not our
friends you are not because when [__]
was hitting the fan they were still
hedging their bets they were not with us
out there putting it all on the line
because Tony I'm sorry but if there's
another Trump trump uh Trump presidency
this isn't hyperbole but you and I are
going to end up in the same freaking
Camp man I
mean this is I mean it's just reality I
will I will be one of the first
[__] they try to track down
because they got to get me to shut the
[__] up um Cassidy is someone here on
twit says Cassidy is dumb but I'm glad
she ratted again that's kind of my point
is that she did Ratt but she ratted
because of her own self-interest she
didn't rat for the interest of the
country democracy she she was told that
she needed to lie in her testimony to
the January 6 select committee and Cassy
Hutchinson had to cross a Rubicon at
some point she had to either say I can't
have this Council that is trying to get
me to lie because they would have known
she'd
lied the the January 6 select committee
would have known she perjured herself
and also it was likely that that same
representation would have representer in
a criminal case against Trump or that
his allies in DC uh in particular her
boss Mark Meadows um and that that is
the thing because these these White
House Council attorneys were telling
Cassidy Hutchinson and others in the wh
house if you do what they say you want
they want you to do you are going to go
to prison it is [__] illegal doing
what they say they're gonna do John
Eastman Jeffrey Clark Hershman was
telling them Hershman was telling them
you better get yourself a damn good
lawyer because you're going to prison my
friend because you're committing [__]
crimes against the United States of
America when you're doing what you're
doing you're trying to commit a coup and
it ain't okay even Hersman that scumbag
was like nope not going to prison for
you Bill bar Bill bar Texas Paul back in
December he he had he had to come to
Jesus moment when he realized that Trump
wanted him to go to federal prison for
him and Bill Bar's like nope not doing
that [__] I'm not doing that and he was
out Cassie Hutchinson had a choice she
could either lie in testimony under oath
or
or she could tell the truth and stay out
of prison and get a book deal to pay for
attorneys that was her choice and she
made the right choice I agree I'm glad
she made the right choice but she made
the right choice in her own
self-interest not in the interest of the
country that's what I'm trying to say
and you're right 100% 100% spoton right
and you know this is how the Russians
get a hold of these people it is that
the Russians will come to you and they
will come with an ask that they know
they can't get from you they they will
Tony they'll say hey I want you to to
I'll give you $10,000 to say all this
right-wing [__] on your show and
you'll say no I'm not doing
it but then they will come back and they
will say wait wait Russians will pay me
to say right-wing [__] on my show how
much will they pay me it's
just just just kidding I'm just kid
someone like Trump someone like Trump
I'll use Trump as an example they'll say
Trump I want you to do this outrageous
thing you know think about a congressman
any Cong pick any Republican Congressman
I want you to do this outrageous thing
for us and you'll say no can't do record
every bit of that
conversation you always cut out when
you're going on a ramp sorry Tony about
that sorry about that but they they will
then the Republicans will come back to
you later and they will they will have
that conversation recorded and they will
say I have you negotiating with me to do
this awful thing it doesn't matter that
you didn't do it I will destroy you with
this this will end your political career
if it comes out so they got you without
even paying you and without you even
doing the awful [__] just by having
their stink on you that's how they open
the door and that's how they start
getting you to do things that actually
do bury you folks these people are in
that position if you look at Cassidy
Hutchinson she knows she's not a babe in
the woods she knows there she worked in
the white house to get Trump elected
Bill bar you use Bill Bar's an example
beautiful example Bill bar did all kinds
of unethical crap for Donald Trump but
he is sitting in front of cameras with
freaking Terror in his eyes telling the
American people do not elect this man
again do not do
it well speaking of
corruption speaking of corruption sorry
I I don't mean to Pivot but I'm going to
Pivot speaking of corruption and um you
know corruption in your state um there's
a guy in your state that's filed a
lawsuit and which leads me uh to having
um the
absolutely great great great guy with
the last name Sanchez on because I
wanted to ask him about this um I know
he's I know he loves Elon don't you
don't you you love Elon I I Can't Get
Enough you can't get enough of Elon did
you hear about this uh this lawsuit that
the Attorney General of Texas Paul State
uh filed um Ken Paxton filed this
speaking of corruption Ken Paxton filed
this U this lawsuit against Media
Matters um the Attorney General Kent
Paxton opens
investigation are you kidding me the
corrupt piece of [__] Ken Paxon open up
to investigation in immediate matters
for potential fraudulent activity so a
fraudster is going to investigate the
frauds Texas Paul and Gabe oh my God so
Gabe have you been on top of this story
yet do you know what's going on I'm sure
you're gonna talk about this on your
show right yeah I've been on a little
bit of it I mean like we have to go back
this is a guy Elon it's all starts with
Elon Musk being upset at Media Matters
for simply tracking the activity on
Twitter whoa whoa wait a second wait
wait a second are you saying that Elon
Musk is mad about fact
is that what you're saying because I
feel like that's what you're saying you
yes that is what I'm saying what you
would what you have to understand is all
they're doing is they're tracking the
activity and they're saying hey look
your platform is
platforming
anti-Semitism uh Nazis far right
extremism all of these things from the
point at which you entered and took over
these are the ch that were made and
these are the effects of said changes
when you go in and you write something
like interesting you know our um uh what
does he say that's the truth that's the
truth interesting surprising like all
these things what what people need to
understand is how the algorithm works
and how Twitter Works where when he
comments someone who has even though he
has a ton of bots he's got 160 million
or whatever followers on on Twitter
because he had to beat Barack Obama you
know he had to get more followers so he
had to pump those numbers get his his
following up and what happens is when a
large account like his a verified
massive master account like his comments
on a one-word thing that says
interesting surprising that's the truth
or whatever he might say it boosts it to
everyone it pushes it into everyone's
feet I mean we have to remember what
happened after the the Super Bowl when
he got triggered that Biden's tweet TW
were performing better than his and he
went to the dev and the dev team and
said hey I want to make sure that this
tweet performs better so then it
artificially injected into everyone's
feeds and that's how verify that's why
when you go into accounts or when you go
into tweets and you look at the comments
the check mark accounts are the ones
that you most you see the most or the
fact that they have a column
specifically for verified feeds even
though verified feeds mean [__] now do
you think because somebody bought paid
eight bucks for it do you think well
it's $22 for Twitter blue now I don't
know if you know that it's it's inflated
yeah $22 um so do you think do you think
yesterday Elon got upset that Joe Biden
posted a picture of his birthday cake
because all the right- wiers are pissed
off that Joe Biden posted a picture of
his birthday I mean they got triggered
like I'm speaking of trigger well it's
not it's not just they got triggered by
the photo they got triggered by the joke
that he made he was like oh I I'm so
happy to be 184 years old is what he
wrote on I think Instagram and then
right-wing news like you can't make that
joke and they're like but you call him
old all the time so when he leans into
Old listen Joe Biden is old but I don't
know what the [__] that has to do with
electing democracy or fascism like fact
that the person that they want as their
president is three years younger but it
it goes back to the idea like Joe Biden
leans into the three years I thought it
was three months I always say three
months is that mean lying oh man because
really the difference between three
years when you're in your 80s is like
three months it really but he pardons a
turkey Biden pardons a turkey and he
goes oh man you know thanks it's like my
six wait he pardoned
Trump you might think you might think
just you an actual turkey I thought you
meant like you might think just based on
the gobbly what is that called again
what what is that called again the the
Bal chinian the Bal balchin
called
here here speaking speaking of turkeys
here's here's um a bunch of turkeys here
uh well let me show it like this here's
stevenh Miller H let's do it like this
so you can see it here's Stephen Miller
here H he tweeted this fraud is both a
civil and criminal violation now I wanna
I want to make sure everyone understands
that Stephen Miller is a head of a of a
legal organization even though he's not
a what is it called Gabe America First
what what no what is it called when
you're when you have a a degree Ree and
then you have the the ability to
practice as a what is it called you pass
the bar and oh oh oh oh you mean um oh
man it's called it's a big it's like
it's really easy to be one in this
country noway it's a okay it's a it
starts with an L well it could start
with an a it could start with an a yes
right um is it is it liar I I don't
think they exist in the Republican party
so I don't know what it is um fraud the
non- lawyer stepen Miller says fraud is
both civil and criminal violation there
are two dozen plus conservative State
Attorneys
generals what what the [__] does that
mean oh oh well Elon will explain what
it means interesting that's what his
go-to is this is how stupid he is that
that interesting
interesting it's also I mean what's
interesting is that elon's like I'm not
racist I'm not a bigot and then he he
comments and platforms a literal [__]
white supremacist Stephen Miller right
he says both civil and criminal and then
my great because I was making fun of
your criminal um attorney general Texas
ball because he is he's a crooked
criminal he's a piece of crap yeah yeah
he should be in [__] prison this
right here is a wle
oh what it is yeah that's my best turkey
there we go you know we got yeah rat's
got the laboratory Gobles but that's my
best all right so here
here is um here is my great attorney
general who's not elected by the way I
don't know if anyone knows that in the
state of Missouri Andrew Bailey is Not
Elected because um our dumbass voted for
Eric Schmidt the former Attorney General
H to be our United States Senator which
was a really dumb move um even worse
that Andrew Bailey a non-elected person
became the Attorney General he says my
team is looking into the
matter they're talking about Media
Matters here but I love how they crowd
do the whole fasy thing and they're like
freedom of speech freedom of speech and
they're talking about suing um Media
Matters for pointing
out the facts that the [__] Twitter
now for known as [__] you know Doom
is [__] X excuse me X I don't call it
X I'm always going to call it Twitter do
it always [__] do it Ken Paxton
[__] do it yeah do it please it is
just bald face documented every person
on freaking Twitter is dragging elen
musk right now putting his post showing
exactly all of the Nazi [__] he
endorsed do it dude please going into
the 2024 elections pretty please go out
there waste my tax dollars on suing on
behalf of elen [__] musk defending
Nazis pretty please take that [__]
stance going into the next election I
will beat your political career to death
with this fact bat I absolutely want you
to do this I want every Republican
attorney general in this country to jump
on the Elon Musk train go after Media
Matters get your ass beat
in court and then I'm going to take it
and I'm going to drag it out I'm going
to wrap it around my fbat and I'm going
to beat your political career to death
with it pretty please do this I'm
begging you I am [__] begging you to
tie yourself to this I'll tell you that
um the the thing that's going to kill
Elon Musk the most and the reason why
this lawsuit won't be dropped it won't
go to court is the reason why is because
Discovery H it's kind of a funny thing
because there's going to be Discovery in
Communications too and the communication
between I don't know Elon and a bunch of
accounts personal uh um communication
between Elon and accounts that are Nazis
that he reinstated on Twitter um so that
it could be more Nazi than it was before
and also all the all the [__] data
showing that these companies
that M mat has pointed out that these
companies were paying for advertising in
Nazi feeds where they were in between
Nazis talking about anti-semitic [__]
and genocide on Jewish people and [__]
where where a Disney ad would appear and
where an Apple ad would appear it ain't
gonna go well that Discovery is not
going to go well for Elon or the [__]
nais um but even my great State Attorney
General and I'm kind of glad this guy's
a dip [__] I'm not going to lie I'm not
going to lie if this guy was smart it
would be much worse but this guy's such
a [__] dumbass um listen listen to
what he says here on Newsmax does it
first off doesn't this guy look like a
Mark Wayne Mullen type Mark they all do
do don't look at this guy looks like he
oh my God this [__] you know I I
would love to meet this guy I wouldn't
want get within spitting distance of him
because I might get in serious trouble
um but let's listen to what let's listen
to what the [__] unelected Missouri
attorney general says about lawsuits
let's listen you're looking into the
matter of what might seem off about this
Media Matters report can you explain uh
what's going on in the office of the
Missouri AG yeah certainly well the
Missouri attorney general's office is
tasked and statute with protecting
Missouri consumers that means cons
consumers that participate on social
media platforms as well and so if we've
got an instance where there was a
deceptive or fraudulent business
practice where Media Matters was using
some kind of coercive or uh fraudulent
uh algorithms or advertising that's
gonna be wait wa wait wait wait what
what Media Matters media wait wait wait
wait did he say did he say that he is
the Missouri attorney general folks he's
the unelected Missouri attorney general
he says he's going to enter this case
and he just said on Newsmax that media
Ms was using an algorithm Media Matters
was using deceptive ad practices what a
[__] does even know who he's suing
Gabe Sanchez does he even know who he's
suing does he know that that that Elon
is using State using state power and
State dollars because he can't sue Media
Matters Elon cannot Sue Media Matters
here it will get thrown out of court the
the big thing I I I think people need to
to realize well yeah is one
Twitter is in control you cannot
manipulate the algorithm unless you go
into the code base and actually change
it yourself so unless somebody hacked
into Twitter and then said hey I want to
change the way in which things are
prioritized or the way in which things
are sorted there's no way that Media
Matters would do that and if that was
the case that shows that there is
deceptive malicious activity but again
that would assume that they hacked into
this private company and then changed
everything and nobody knew about it that
is what this dumbass is is basically
saying because they have no control over
it all they're doing is saying hey look
Hitler commentary anti-semitic
commentary IBM ad anti-semitic
commentary Apple ad it's just
screenshots that's all it is it's it's
literally screenshots and or video
recordings of them saying ad
anti-Semitism ad anti-Semitism Nazi
stuff anti-Semitism ad and they also
have the data Twitter has the data
meaning that Twitter has the data
because what what's funny about all this
the the most hilarious thing before we
go because we got to get to your show
too yeah here in five minutes four
minutes um before I let you go over
there but the because here's I'll maybe
I'll Quee you up for you to talk about
this is the best part about this the
funniest part about this whole thing is
the right-wingers who are making 90% of
the ad dollars that Nazis and the
anti-semites who are making 90% of these
ad even so [__] pissed off because
their stupid Nazi rhetoric has now made
all the ad dollars leave their [__]
threads which has left them broke what's
the funniest part that's not the
funniest part funniest part is watching
people like Benny Johnson and Tim p and
other right-wing people think now people
need to realize that Apple was putting I
think a hundred million dollar into
advertising [__] huge numbers okay
millions of dollars and Tim p goes yeah
I'll throw
$250,000 or whatever it was some dumb
number which is like you cannot exist on
this platform or allow this platform to
exist any longer if you start throwing
[__] pennies into the bucket when
someone was throwing $100 bills and when
they remove that money ak apple IBM
Disney any one of these other people who
said n we don't really want to associate
ourselves with anti-Semitism or Nazis or
Hitler and then you have right-wing
commentators think that their money is
worth anything sure it might cover some
expenses for the month but if you're
talking about the annual budget [__]
that man you guys are a [__] joke and
that's the funniest part them thinking
that their dollars are are ever going to
change the trajectory of Twitter getting
back in or or actually getting into the
black because they're in the [__] red
month after
month
well there's another there's another
great there's another great um fact here
is that you know we have to um we have
to get to your show so yeah dude where's
my
car dude dude where's your car where's
your car I don't I don't know last
update I called the cops yesterday I
called the police and I was like hey I
know you're supposed to call me is there
any update they're like nope still
stolen so oh oh well you'll find it
eventually you'll find it eventually
Gabe Sanchez go find go find go find
your show go find go all right all right
go on go find your show I'll see you
guys later
get the hell out of
here Tony God I hope they do this I hope
to God I they are doing it Kim pax's
already done it I I I I love this it's
just like when tuberville came out
talking about white supremacist in the
military and everybody in the Republican
party went well there's no way to un
tuberville this by making it about
abortion they have nailed themselves to
freaking elen mus cross and I absolutely
love this they cannot put this crap back
in the horse I am just I am
I dude I got wood right now I'm telling
you I got wood right now I am telling
you I am dying to take this into the
political Arena
please let me do
this he's got wood folks he's got wood
and he's got the fact bet all right go
visit real texas.com that's real
texas.com links down below go check out
Paul's show on Sunday and Wednesdays he
won't be here next week because he won't
have any fingers because he's fighting
he's fighting the Gopher Army in his
backyard so next week he won't be with
us because he'll be having surgery uh
trying to reattach his fingers from D
dynamiting the Gophers in the backyard
but but he'll be back he'll be back I'll
be back tomorrow we're not again we're
not gonna have a show Thursday Friday
look for the merch promo codes tonight
on social media they'll start at
midnight tonight they're going to go
through Sunday I'll see you guys
tomorrow I promise tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow same time same place Serv that
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at@ the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking